[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOYCE BAZ: By welcoming
a very special guest.
Here today, Mina Al
Oriabi, the Editor
In Chief of "The National."
Mina, you've been a
political journalist
for a very, very,
very long time.
How did it all begin
and what was the genesis
of your career, if you will?
MINA AL ORIABI: Right.
So first of all, thank you
so much for being here.
And thank you, Joyce,
for not only hosting me,
but Google has been really kind
to "The National," since we
relaunched last July.
So it's very nice to
continue our relationship.
I'm Iraqi-British, and I
think for many people who
are from countries that either
suffer war or dictatorship
or whatever, it really dominates
your life in different ways.
Unfortunately, I
count myself as lucky
because we left
when I was a child.
We left Iraq when I was a child.
But still politics kind
of has shaped who I am
and where I came to.
And in a way, I think
that's what determined my
getting involved in journalism
and wanting to understand more
but also cast a light
on certain issues.
So really, I think it has to do
with the fact that I am Iraqi,
and I also love storytelling--
so combine the two together.
JOYCE BAZ: So
political journalism--
I don't think there
was ever a time
when it was easy or risk-free.
Would you say that being a
political journalist today
comes with an even higher
set of risks and challenges
than in the past, or was
there never an easy time?
MINA AL ORIABI: I don't think
there's ever an easy time.
But again, I think if we're
talking about the Middle East
and North Africa, at the
moment, unfortunately, half
the time that people are
thinking you're a journalist,
you have to be a
war correspondent.
And that's really difficult. I
remember the first journalism
story I ever wrote in political
journalism was in 2002,
and it was the one million
person march in London
against the upcoming
war in Iraq.
And I remember at
the time thinking,
I really should be going
to Iraq to cover this.
But I'll be really frank.
My parents were like,
there is no way on Earth
you're getting to Iraq.
And you're staying here, and
you're safer here and so forth.
And to be fair, I
remember thinking,
I'm a lesser journalist
for not being out
there on the front line.
And I had a great mentor,
who's still a friend,
and who actually now writes
for "The National," which
I'm really proud of.
But he was this big journalist,
and I had a word with him.
And he said to me, Mina,
not every journalist
has to be a war correspondent.
War correspondents do incredible
work and incredible stories,
but you can still do the
other types of stories.
And I said, well,
what I really am
interested in is the policy
side and the thematic side.
And sometimes,
fortunately, especially
with what we're seeing at
the moment with UN failures
and other problems with the
international community,
you still want to
write about those
and explain those and also have
the context and the sourcing
of piecing together a story.
So that's the field I went into.
And I studied
history at university
partly because I
wanted to know how
did we get here in order
to frame anything that I'm
going to be writing about.
And so that's the
difficulty of one.
If you're a war
correspondent, I think
the dangers are so much
more today than they
were 15, 20, 30 years ago.
It's incredible, and I
think that journalism
is poorer for it,
especially as we're
trying to understand what's
happening in different conflict
zones around the world.
And that suddenly having a
flak jacket that says "press,"
you're almost the target
whereas before, that
would be your safety.
So I think that's one concern.
Political journalists
of course also
carry different types of risks.
So where do you cross a
line that can get you--
the only trouble you can
get your organization
in trouble and so forth.
And of course, now, it's
funny because before censors,
if you're working
in the newspaper,
you just have to
skim the newspaper
and things can pass
whereas now with one
keyword alert search can
unravel a whole host of things.
So it's changed for sure.
JOYCE BAZ: And do you feel that
being a political journalist
in the Middle East and
also being a woman poses
an extra set of challenges?
MINA AL ORIABI: I think every
job has its own challenges.
And I think in journalism,
you have different challenge,
especially as we see
disruption that's
happening in the media industry
and trying to figure out
how do you get the right story.
The pressure now to
get the story out,
even if you haven't
double-sourced or triple
sourced for confirmation.
Being a woman, yes, of course,
has its own set of challenges.
And I also think, especially
in the Middle East,
there's certain conceptions
about women in media.
And I remember when I first said
I wanted to go into journalism,
my mother was quite disapproving
and not because of me.
But she said, you'll
find so many challenges
in how you'll be perceived
as a woman and so forth.
She quickly changed her
mind, which was good
and my father too--
they were really encouraging.
But they were
concerned because they
felt that in our
societies, there
is a certain element of
prejudice against women
in the media sector.
I think that's changed.
I do think opening up of
everything from the variety
of outlets we now have.
Television has changed.
But it's a bit of that
perception remains.
JOYCE BAZ: And do
you feel there's
good representation in media
and journalism today of women?
MINA AL ORIABI: I'm very proud
of "The National," there is.
But I think across the board,
no, we still face challenges.
I think there are
still issues primarily
to do with gender gaps
in pay for sure that I
think that's one of
the biggest challenges.
And compensation
is really important
because that's got to
do with confidence.
It's got to do with how
you feel that you're
being valued as a
journalist, regardless
of your gender or your sex.
So it's still a huge issue
and across the board,
across the world.
JOYCE BAZ: OK.
So if we were to dig in a
bit more into your career,
what was the hardest interview
you've ever had to do and why?
MINA AL ORIABI: So I
was thinking about this
because you said to me you
may ask about the hardest
interview.
So I was really
thinking about this,
and there are so
many different ones.
One that was really
difficult for me--
but then I was really proud of
was interviewing the daughters
of the lady who was
killed in Nassau Square
that famous Blackwater
incident in Baghdad
when you had suddenly these
young girls were orphans.
Their father had
died previously.
Their mother had
worked as a driver
to try to get some sort
of income to come in,
and she was shot, with several
other civilians, by Blackwater.
And so I went to
interview them in Jordan.
It was really difficult because
their story had to be told,
but they were so emotional.
And I was also
getting emotional,
and I was trying not to
because I felt like--
but I also wanted to show
them empathy, and I felt it.
It was really difficult
to interview them.
It took a long time,
and I went to visit them
several times before I could
even write something or have
them open up.
And it's always difficult with
these human interest stories
because you want to
tell their story,
but you also don't want to pry.
And there is a
sense of what right
do I have-- a complete stranger
they've just met-- to say, how
do you feel about your mother?
How do you feel about
what's happened in Iraq?
Where's your future going?
So that, for me, was
emotionally really difficult.
And then there are
difficult people
like officials that you
end up having to interview.
They're not really interested
in giving interviews.
So it's like you
ask them a question
and give you a one-word answer.
And you're like why
am I doing this?
But they're part of the job.
But the ones that are difficult
are emotional ones, actually.
JOYCE BAZ: And if you were to
do one more interview again
with a person you've
interviewed, who would it be?
MINA AL ORIABI: With somebody
I've already interviewed?
Good question.
Nouri al-Maliki, former
prime minister of Iraq.
I interviewed him when
he was prime minister,
and I'd be quite tempted to
interview him again and see
where we were.
I think that would
be quite interesting.
JOYCE BAZ: Great, so there
are Gallup polls in the US
that show a significant drop in
trust in mass media in America.
But many would argue that this
does not apply in the Middle
East, and a lot of research
shows that trust in mass media
is still very high.
What would you say about that?
What are your thoughts on it?
Is there a continuous
trust in mass media
in our part of the world?
MINA AL ORIABI: I think
there is more trust
because the alternatives in,
especially the Arabic language,
have been so weak and
are so untrustworthy.
So I think that's when
actually more legacy
media, traditional
media, mass media trust
is there because
the alternatives.
And we've seen the amount
of really shoddy fake news.
Like it's so obvious
that this is fake
that people don't catch
on to it in the same way
that you've had in other
places that more sophisticated.
I also think there's more
trust because, in some way,
we almost know the biases of
different or editorial lines
of different organizations.
So people know that when
they're coming to it kind
of what they're receiving, and
then they make their judgment
call whereas
especially in the US,
I find it fascinating when they
speak of American journalists.
There's this thing
of we're objective,
and I genuinely don't believe.
I think everything
is subjective.
The headline we
choose is subjective.
The photo we choose to
be on the front page
or the top of your home
page is subjective.
Everything is subjective
whereas in the US,
for the longest
time, it was always,
no, everything is objective,
and it's a level playing field.
And it's not and
doesn't necessarily
have to mean that you have
a bias with ill intent,
but I think you do have bias
is based on your knowledge,
on your personal
experience, on who's
actually in the newsroom,
who's making the shot.
And so I think in
the US, there's
less trust now because
people bought into this idea
that everything's objective.
And suddenly, they're like,
oh, no, it's actually not.
JOYCE BAZ: It's hard to be.
So Mina, you are British-Iraqi.
You grew up in Sweden, and you
lived in Australia and the UK.
What should we know about
Mina that we won't find
in a quick search on Google?
MINA AL ORIABI: I
think one of the things
that when I first speak,
people are always like, oh,
where did the accent come from?
And I first learned to
speak English in Australia.
So I had a proper Aussie
accent that I lost.
But I was a child, we
lived in Australia.
And then I left Australia,
and I lost my Aussie accent.
So I guess that's one thing
most people don't know about me.
JOYCE BAZ: Well, you
can always get it again
after living in the UAW with
such a mixed expat community.
MINA AL ORIABI: Well, it's
funny because this accent
is from years of
living in Saudi Arabia.
And then I moved to
the UK when I was 15,
and I never picked
up a British accent
whereas my sister, who's older,
picked up a British accent.
I don't know.
Maybe I watch too
much Hollywood.
It's never changed.
JOYCE BAZ: So you were appointed
editor in chief last year
for "The National."
And one of the things
you said were you
want to take a new and
fresh approach to news.
What did you mean by that?
MINA AL ORIABI: Well,
several things--
I think the most important
part of any news organization
newsroom is the team and
how you're putting together
different teams.
And what capabilities and
how you're equipping them--
and this is a challenge
we still haven't cracked.
At "The National," we
continue to work on it--
is how we make sure that you
give each journalist the chance
to--
whether they're editing, whether
they're using multimedia,
whether they're writing--
chance to develop
different ideas
because you need
expertise, but you also
need them to breakout of it.
So for example, we
try to make sure
that everybody has
the chance to write
about either their
favorite books--
or they could be genuinely
writing usually or just
a subeditor every day.
But then they have the chance to
write about sports or so forth.
So giving them a more rounded
approach to telling stories,
and that's what we hope
to do at "The National."
So that's one element of it.
The second element also of
it is getting that balance
between yes, we have
to be up to date,
but we're never going
to be a newswire.
So there's that.
For many newspapers,
there's that tension now
because you want to be the
first person to break something,
but that's not really
our raison d'etre.
Our raison d'etre
is to make sure
that we're giving
you an analysis.
Why do you care about this?
Why is the story important?
And so getting
that balance right.
We have an integrated newsroom.
So people are working towards
our digital outlets but also
the actual physical
print newspaper.
So taking that approach of
one, it's integrated, and two,
how are we understanding
reader behavior and therefore,
making sure that our stories
are being updated and developed
in a way that suits the
reader to come back and have
fresh stories.
But also not getting
into this rat race of we
have to update every two
minutes or five minutes.
JOYCE BAZ: And I must say
I'm not being biased here.
But "The National's"
website is probably
one of the greatest
news sites out there
today covering the region.
And if you haven't listened
to "The National's" podcast,
you should definitely
try it out.
It's really good, and
it's a good chance
to go deep and have
long-form conversations.
MINA AL ORIABI: Thank
you for saying that.
I mean, the thing with the
podcast and other things--
we relaunched July 2017.
And we had a very short
time to turn things around.
But one of the things is, for
example, on the podcasting,
there were people who never
sat behind a microphone before,
and so we're really
nervous about it.
And we gave them basic training.
It wasn't something
long over months.
We didn't have the time--
a few days of it.
But giving them and
equipping them with skills.
And then seeing
who wants to do it.
So rather than assign people
and say, you have to do this.
You have to that, It was people
coming forward and saying,
actually, yes, I
think I could do that
and seeing that they
have the skills.
So that's been actually
one of the things
that I'm really proud
of "The National."
That we've tried these
things, and people
have been great
journalists, want
to tell stories
in different ways,
and they've been
able to do that.
JOYCE BAZ: So news
consumption is
becoming more fragmented and
more digital than ever before.
How are you guys receiving
this at "The National,"
and what are you
doing to change it
and to transform into digital?
MINA AL ORIABI: That's
the big question, I think,
for all newspapers.
And so part of it, like
I said, is understanding
what our readers actually want.
And you all know this.
There is your core
loyal group of readers,
who will always come
to "The National,"
and they've downloaded our app.
When they wake up
in the morning,
they have to look at it,
or they go to the website.
And they're, at the moment,
comprising about 50%
of our readership.
And a little over 50%
are coming through search
and of course, Google being
the primary resource for that.
But also coming through
social media and sharing.
And so you all notice all
these changes happening
to what makes you read a story?
Is it because
someone you trust--
again, it goes back to
the element of trust--
has sent it to you,
and therefore, you
think it's worth your time?
So we're trying to develop way
that we have our core readers,
and we grow our base of the
loyal readers that will always
come back.
And then also catering
for those people
that are finding us,
because of a certain topic
we've written about through
search or social media.
So that's something
that you never
had to worry about in
a newspaper before.
And just 15 years ago, you
would be what's the front page?
How are we making sure that
we've got a good spread of news
over 40 pages?
And you're kind of that was it.
And now it's completely changed
in terms of prioritization.
And also, you can't
control how you're
going to have that
experience with a reader
if they're coming to you only
through search or social.
But you want to keep
them on the page
in order to stay engaged
and actually think, hey,
yes, "The National"
has more to offer me
than this immediate
story that I'm going to.
So that's really
part of our everyday
in terms of we're
curating the home page
and the website,
how we're curating
the app, what we're putting out
through our social media feeds.
And I always say we have five
outlets now at "The National."
We have the paper,
which I'm very proud of,
but it's only in the UAE.
So you only see it
if you're in the UAE.
You've got the website, which
again, is the main source
of our readership now.
You've got the app, and
we have the e-reader,
which is just the basic
kind of readership
and that's what a
lot of people go for.
But we have the more
sophisticated app
that actually is more
curated, and then we've
got our social media feeds.
And then we've got
the fifth element,
which is our very specific
products like our newsletter,
that lands in your inbox every
morning, and our podcast.
And sometimes, we have
videos that are purely video.
There's no other story to go
with it because we're also
expanding our multimedia.
So working across those five
every day is very challenging.
It's not easy, but
it's also keeping
that priority of seeing that's
how we're reaching a greater
readership now.
JOYCE BAZ: Do you envision
a day where you will start
distributing your print paper?
It's a tough question.
MINA AL ORIABI:
Everybody asks that.
I don't want to.
I don't want to stop
distributing a print paper,
but I have to envision
that because if that's
where the market will go, then
you have to prepare for it.
I don't think that's going to
happen for various reasons.
One, I think there is
still something to be
said about reading a newspaper.
My niece is three years old.
And when I go visit my sister,
I always take the paper with me,
and I put in front of her so
she can play with it because I'm
thinking, if we can get children
to play with newspapers,
they're going to
enjoy reading it,
like we enjoy reading
newspapers now.
What I worry about is that most
toddlers and young children now
are always just
holding a device.
So they won't even know
what to do with the paper.
So my niece and nephew
are being indoctrinated.
My nephew's a year and
a half, so he's still
got a year or two to go.
But my niece is
totally indoctrinated.
And so I think that
experience, as long as people
find joy in having that.
It's an experience-- having your
coffee and your morning paper
and all of that.
So long as that
exists, then we'll
stay good because I think
we're a competitive newspaper,
and people want to read us.
However, if with time,
people's behavior just
no longer includes
that little ritual,
then it's very hard to keep up
JOYCE BAZ: We have
our very own image
of newspapers at our reception.
You'll go in, and you'll
see lots of print papers
decorating our section.
We can start to warm up with
questions from the room.
I will ask my last
question here,
and it's somewhat of
an existential one.
With spread of
misinformation that we're
seeing around the
world today, how do you
see the future of journalism?
I know you wrote a piece
for the World Economic Forum
that the future is credibility.
But how do you see that rolling
out-- the future of journalism
in an age where there's more
and more misinformation?
MINA AL ORIABI: I
think as awareness
is raised about this
issue of misinformation,
I do think people are
more aware today than they
were maybe two years ago.
So I think as more and more
of that becomes a problem,
it actually works
better for journalism
because you go back to the
basics of journalism, which
is how do we get the story?
What's our source?
What's the credibility behind
tell all aspects of the story?
If I've missed something about
the aspects of the story,
am I making my reader
aware and so forth?
So I think that stays true.
And if you get that right, with
time, people come back to it.
I say, as a newspaper, we
compete with everything
from Twitter to Google News
to "The Economist," which
used to be-- if you're
a newspaper in the UAE,
who cares what "The
Economist" is writing?
But now, they're
distributing here,
and we're also trying to
reach an audience sitting
in the UK or the US.
So that change
means that you have
to be strong in your
journalism in order
for people to come to you,
rather than fake news that's
just being shared around.
So I think there's
more awareness,
and I do think it's
a challenge now.
But with time, people
getting to know
if you take a screen
grab of a tweet
and you haven't sent
me the actual tweet,
it means the screen
grab is something that's
photoshopped and fabricated.
We're still not there,
but I think more people
are becoming aware of that.
So it's also part of
our job, as journalists,
to raise awareness about that.
And I do think that media
literacy, with time,
will actually be part
of people's education.
Like to be well-rounded, you're
going to have to understand.
Just like we talk about
financial literacy,
I think we need to talk
about media literacy
and understanding information.
And if that really kicks in--
which I think it's beginning
to in certain parts--
then it holds drills I
mean, and good stuff.
JOYCE BAZ: Great, that's
great final words.
Questions from the room?
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for joining us
at [INAUDIBLE] So you said
you studied [INAUDIBLE]
heart of Mina for the past--
for all of your career.
If your niece asks you
today, how did we get here?
How would you answer that?
MINA AL ORIABI: Wow, I guess
it depends where here is.
So I would probably
first talk about Iraq
because I'm a
single issue voter.
If I was in the US, I'd
say I'm a single issue
voter because everything
goes back to Iraq,
which is rightly or wrongly.
And I think with Iraq, it
was just failed leadership.
And I think,
unfortunately, for Iraq,
I can say that with
absolute certainty,
knowing the ins
and outs of it all.
I think also, as you
said, I studied history.
When you look at history,
the impact that leadership
can have at taking you on the
right course or the completely
wrong course, especially
when many of our societies
are top-down.
So how the top goes
can really impact that.
I'd say that's probably
my immediate answer.
My second answer of
how did we get here
is also a lack of
vision, not knowing
where we want to
be in four years
time, five years time, 20
years time, rather everything
was so immediate
and reactionary.
And I think that's been
one of our pitfalls.
But I also I hope that
I can say to her, well,
we got to here as
women, as societies
that there are some progressive
elements that we don't
necessarily always see because
me, as a political journalist,
always thinks of the
current affair status, which
depresses me.
But when you think about
also society and how
we've been able to either
build bridges or push back
against stereotypes, then that's
also the strength of people.
And I think we've been really
lucky with immigration.
Unfortunately, now we're
seeing a trend against.
But I think with
immigration both ways--
people coming to the region,
leaving from the region
so forth.
We've seen some great dynamic,
I think, leaps in society.
And so that I would say
is also people movement,
and people's mobility
has been a good thing--
when it's not forced, of course.
AUDIENCE: Hello, thank you.
That was fascinating.
As it's International
Women's Day,
what's your take with your
international perspective
on the current perspective
outside the current narrative
about women [INAUDIBLE]
and how do you
think it's evolving over time?
MINA AL ORIABI: Again, I think
we talk about the Middle East,
and it's so different
from country to country.
And so it is kind
of incredible here I
moved to [INAUDIBLE]
on the 1 of March 2017.
It's the first time I live in
the Arab world, as an adult.
So I've been going
back and forth.
I've actually never
lived here as an adult.
And so I had friends.
I have colleagues,
contacts saying,
you're going to
struggle as a woman.
I said, actually, it's been
amazing because I'm actually
in a country where I feel
comfortable as a woman.
And I genuinely mean that.
This is not because
the camera's rolling.
I genuinely mean that,
and that's amazing.
And I'm not sure how
many other places.
I could say that about.
And I go into a room, and
I find that most times,
people are gender-blind,
which is really rare anywhere
in the world.
Having said that, we're talking
about Middle Eastern women.
And there is that
stereotype of either
it's like this curious
mysterious veiled oriental
woman that still exists in
today's world, which is crazy
or the opposite that
they're all trailblazers.
But then there are women
that are being left behind,
partly because of
our wider societal
and political problems,
especially, for example,
they always talk about the
impact of war on society.
So in some ways, it forces
women to go out and perhaps take
jobs they wouldn't
have taken before.
We saw that, of course, with
World War II and the impact
it had on Europe.
And part of that is happening.
But at the same
time, war is actually
making women's rights in
certain parts of the Middle East
really regress.
So it's linked to
fear, intimidation,
how can you intimidate women?
And my father's family
is from Mosul in Iraq.
And Mosul was subjected to
horrific reign of terror
under Daesh, and so
the only difference
between my cousins and I--
my father left, and their
father didn't, basically.
And so the way that
it was actually women
and how they were forced to
get completely covered up.
And their identity stripped from
them and they couldn't work,
and they couldn't do
all these things--
that targeting of women,
as we were seeing,
is actually making them progress
because even after Daesh
goes or different
extremist elements go,
it's still really hard
to break out of it.
So it's really a mixed bag.
But in terms of international
perceptions of Middle Eastern
women, unfortunately, it's
still so stereotypical
and quite shallow.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much for that.
I have a question around the
edutainment value of media.
And in order to get
the attention, in order
to capture the attention of the
audience, what we're seeing now
in my view is these
images and stories
that are really shock value.
And I'm not talking
about fake news.
I'm talking about things that
are really happening, but has
really shocking images
What's your view of that?
Is this valid or what?
MINA AL ORIABI: I think
probably the Syria story is one
that increasingly, we're
seeing shocking images,
partly because of
how horrifically
the situation is there.
But partly-- and
this term really
frustrates me as a
journalist-- you get people
saying we have reader fatigue.
So we need to shock
people into caring.
And I say, first of
all, I'm sorry you're
tired that people are
dying, and their lives
are being destroyed.
I find that really offense
as a term but anyway.
And then the second
thing of actually,
those shocking images--
if you don't already
care, I honestly
don't think that's
going to make you care.
It may make you stop and say,
OK, why do I make you stop?
And I don't think it's going
to make you care or move you
to act because it's more
brutal or more shocking.
So that's kind of the approach
we've taken at "The National."
At "The National,"
we have really,
really strict
guidelines in terms
of what we're actually
publishing, in terms of photos,
in terms of headlines.
It's really difficult
because you see--
this image I think most of
you will conjure up now--
the bodies of children
wrapped in white shrouds.
And it's been really hard for
us because people are like, oh,
well, it tells a story.
Of course, Palestine
we have these images.
For decades, we've seen them
coming out of Palestine.
And it's always
been a thing of, OK,
but what is the dignity of
that child and their family?
This isn't their
choice to be published.
And also the shock element
should be about the fact
that it's happening.
We can't be so graphic
that we desensitize.
It's difficult because now
everybody can be a publisher
because if I don't publish
it, somebody else is going
to put it on
whatever page it is,
whether it's a Facebook page or
their own website and so forth.
So then do you lose out?
Should we take at
"The National?"
It's fine, we can lose out.
But I think we need to shake
people from complacency,
and it can't be done by
abusing actually the victims.
So it's constantly
a conversation
that we have in our newsroom.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] how do
you compare it as an outside
and how does it affect
you as a journalist?
MINA AL ORIABI: Sure.
So that's, of course, one
topic that comes up a lot.
And I have to say, every
outlet that I've either
worked for or been a
guest of, a panel of
has its own guidelines and
own issues that come up,
and they're different.
They're different--
whether it's commercial,
whether it's political, we
go back to the point of ISIS.
Do you call them ISIS,
the Isha Islamic State?
I used to go on the BBC
many times to discuss it,
and I'd be so angry because
they'd say Islamic state.
I'm like it's not
the Islamic State,
and the anchor would
be looking at me,
like can you just like leave
that discussion to later?
Because we need to
get to where we are.
So that's one thing.
And then there is the issue of
freedom of expression as such.
And I think freedom
of expression
as a concept is different
in different societies,
and it's really interesting
because recently, I
was speaking to an
American official.
And the way she was speaking
about freedom of speech
is completely different from
how, for example, in the UK,
they speak about
freedom of expression
and the whole first
amendment and so forth.
" then in our region, it's
much more about looking
at journalism as being
responsible journalism.
And that has its
pluses and its minuses
because again, going
back to that point.
I do actually think that
there are certain constraints
that we place on
ourselves that we have to.
And then there are
certain tricky topics
that it would be I think wrong
and disingenuous to say, yeah,
it's absolutely the
same, whether you're
in the Arab world or abroad.
I think it's different.
It's different in China.
It's different in Russia.
It's a constant juggle.
And one of the things that
you have to think about
is one, the safety of the
people who work for you,
two, what is the longevity
of your establishment?
So for example, again,
you'll have certain entities
that are commercial
entities that you
want to stay on the right
side of one way or the other,
to make sure that
you can continue.
And that's not "The National"
but for other enterprises.
And then there's
the politics, and I
think you have to be really
careful about what you do
and how you write about it.
But in all seriousness
and honesty,
it's not a constraint for
us because actually, there
are clear editorial
guidelines that I adhere
to that I believe, and
the newsroom also adheres
to and is happy with it, in
terms of the battle of ideas.
Where do we stand
in the Middle East
and especially in
the Arab world?
The situation where we're
in right now, in terms of,
do we believe in enforcing
religion into politics?
Do we believe in the use of
arms outside of state rule?
And all of that stuff.
And so we have, again,
clear lines on that.
And that's where we stick to.
So for us, that's
how we approach it.
I think for others, it
comes down to what's
politically acceptable?
What's politically unacceptable?
And there are very
few-- people always
ask me what are the red lines?
I'm like, honestly, there
are no red lines and such,
but there is an understanding
of our societies
and where we're publishing.
And this goes back to
the digital element
because sometimes,
you're writing something
that will work for
a reader that's
in your immediate vicinity.
That would be
completely different
if they're Australian.
And so we think about
who's our core audience,
and who are our core readers.
And we and we stick with that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MINA AL ORIABI: You choose
to ask the questions.
You touched upon media
literacy now looking
at the general Arabic-speaking
public in the Middle East.
Obviously, I have my own
opinion about the quality
of the literacy we have.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering,
what do you think about it?
Do you think there is high media
literacy in the Middle East?
Because we know that there
are many Arab journalists who
are doing excellent
work but there's also
a lot of journalists who
are doing horrible work.
So what do you think
about Arab media literacy?
And if you can
improve it or if you
think it needs improvement,
what would you do?
MINA AL ORIABI: So when I
say media literacy, I mean--
so I'm just making sure
we're on the same page.
When I say media literacy,
it's basically all of us--
how we understand news and
how we're consuming it.
So it's for the reader or
the consumer or the viewer.
Again, I think it's varied
from country to country,
but I don't think
there is a high level
of media illiteracy in the
Arab world or internationally.
But if we're sticking to just
the Arab world, absolutely not.
There isn't enough
understanding or awareness.
You still get people saying,
I read it on the internet.
And you're like,
OK, congratulations.
Where on the internet?
And so that's partly
because technological change
has happened so quickly.
But partly because it's not
part of our school ethos.
This is not something
that you teach in schools.
Again, if people have
strong history classes
and they understand
sourcing, then it
gets ingrained with that.
But most unfortunately,
in most of the Arab world,
history curricula is
not taught that way.
It's not taught for critical
thinking or questioning.
Did this actually happen the way
I'm being told it's happening?
So it's completely different.
So we don't have
high media literacy.
What would I change about it?
I would honestly bring
in classes into schools.
I would open up for more
journalists to go and speak.
When I was living in the UK,
I would often go to schools.
In the UK, and
actually, in the US,
I did this-- spoke at
schools and so forth.
It's much more difficult here
to actually have the access
to go and speak about them.
So I would do a program, where
I would have schools partner up
with journalists to go
and speak about these.
And again, just simple
things like sourcing.
How do you see if a photo is
photoshopped or otherwise?
Because I think that's a life
skill that's really important.
So I would start quite young.
But then also older--
just simple things.
Like you can't say, I
read that on the internet.
What does that mean?
And sometimes,
don't even realize
but when you have
that conversation,
they'll be like, oh, yeah.
I wrote an article
for a [INAUDIBLE],,
my former employers--
still people call them.
But when I wrote an article that
was really popular a few weeks
ago, because I said,
you, the reader,
have a responsibility
for what you're sharing,
you get these WhatsApp
messages that says in Arabic
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
and it basically says,
as I received it, as I got it.
And it's like what?
And it's rubbish-- what
they're sending makes no sense.
And you're like, how
can you send this
and then just write back
and say, just what I got.
I held no responsibility.
Because you actually do
hold the responsibility--
you're sharing it.
So then to tell people
that they actually
have a responsibility
as publishers
but also distributors.
JOYCE BAZ: Wow,
lots of questions.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yes, I was just
interviewing Barack Obama.
MINA AL ORIABI: Oh,
this was interesting.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MINA AL ORIABI: Yeah,
oh, my god-- so many.
OK.
JOYCE BAZ: Which year was this?
MINA AL ORIABI: Wow, I
should remember this.
2011, I want to say.
Yeah, 2011.
OK, so I interviewed
American officials
during the Bush administration
times and the Obama times.
The Bush administration people
were so much more accessible,
and they had no red lines.
The only things they
would have is you
only have the time frame.
I interviewed Obama
and Kerry, and they
were so difficult because
Obama-- they wouldn't even
let me go see him.
So we did it actually by phone.
And I said I'll fly.
I'll come anytime they want.
And they said no,
and they wanted
to control it completely.
And the same was
true actually when
they-- although Kerry was
more fun because he actually
was like-- he was trying to be
like we've known each other.
And I don't know him.
But with Obama, it
was really controlled.
It was absolutely controlled.
The questions were controlled.
And it was really
disappointing, to be honest.
With the Bush
administration, I didn't
interview Bush or Cheney, but
I interviewed many others.
And honestly, the only
constraint would be the time--
like you have half an hour.
Do what you want.
So they really
controlled the message,
and they believed I worked
in Washington from beginning
of 2009 to end of 2011.
They believed that
all we need to do
is tweet something out or send
you an SMS message saying,
we're going to send you a speech
that he gave, and that's it.
I had only one background
briefing with the White House
the entire time I was there.
And then I had a couple
of other interviews,
like with Ben Rhodes
and other people.
But they really
controlled the message,
and I think it was to their
detriment internationally.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] what
your life would be like
if your parents
hadn't [INAUDIBLE]..
What's the picture
that comes to mind?
MINA AL ORIABI:
Like I said, it's
the only difference
between me and my cousins
is that my cousins
didn't leave, and I did.
But it's also incredible
how resilient they are
and how much fun they are.
I saw them recently--
a few of them.
For people from the Middle East,
like we say, I have a cousin,
and there's like 45 of them.
Genuinely, I think I
have like 47 cousins.
And so it's incredible
how similar we are,
and I think, again,
that's blood.
It's incredible.
Some of my cousins,
I hadn't seen--
my family was in exile
from 1919 to 2003.
So I didn't see
family for that long.
And we went back to
Baghdad at the end of 2003,
and it was incredible like I'd
seen them just last weekend.
So that's amazing how
like through inheritance
and through your parents'
upbringing and so forth,
you're so similar.
But life would have been
so much more difficult.
I definitely wouldn't have
had most of the opportunities
I've had, but I would say
in terms of confidence,
I see that in my cousins.
In terms of aspirations
and so forth,
it kind of hasn't
beat them down--
all the craziness
that's happened in Iraq.
If you're from my
generation, you
were born in the time when
there's the Iran-Iraq war.
You finished that, then you
had the Kuwait invasion.
You finished that, you had
the years of sanctions.
You finished the
years of sanctions,
you go into the 2003 war.
You go into sectarian strife.
You go into ISIS, and
here we are today.
So people who are of that
generation-- and especially
actually, for many men
who are slightly older,
who actually had to be
drafted into the army,
it's heartbreaking
because the years
that they spent being drafted
into these senseless wars.
So I think if I had stayed
in Iraq and if I was a man,
it would have been
actually that much worse.
But at the same time, I
think I would probably
be very similar in character
because of what my parents have
instilled in me.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for being here.
I want to go back to a question
regarding [INAUDIBLE] freedom
of speech.
[INAUDIBLE] context of the
audiences, and audiences
[INAUDIBLE] journalists duty
to actually push the boundaries
[INAUDIBLE] are accustomed
to being exposed to?
MINA AL ORIABI: Yeah and
we do want certain things.
So again, it's a fine line,
and it's a negotiation.
It's a negotiation with
yourself, with your editor.
There's no external power
that comes and tells you, do,
do not.
Definitely, in the Emirates, we
don't live in that landscape.
I think it's different depending
on the country you're in.
It's an appreciation
and understanding
of what would be acceptable,
what isn't acceptable.
But I mean, to political
powers, not only to audiences.
So it's your own [INAUDIBLE].
So it's also your
negotiation, and there
are things that you choose.
And you say, no, I'm
going to push on this.
And we have had
issues like that.
And to be frank, I mean, touch
wood before I jinx myself.
Since July 1 until now,
there's not been one thing that
you've had somebody
turn around and say, no,
you cannot write that.
Now does that mean
that we're careful,
and therefore, we
haven't pushed?
I think we have pushed
on certain issues.
I don't know how frequently
you read "The National."
But we do try,
especially on issues
that we think are
of public interest,
and that is kind of
like our guiding force.
But again, I don't
mean to belittle it,
but it really isn't that
big a constraint once you
know what you want to
be out there saying
and why you're working
in the Middle East.
I mean, there is a joy
to working from here
to be able to say there's
a publication coming out
from the Arab world that
is able to tackle issues--
social issues but
also political issues,
questions, certain things.
Again, not easy-- we're not
going to do irresponsibly.
But there is a joy in
being able to do that.
JOYCE BAZ: Any more questions?
AUDIENCE: I have one.
[INAUDIBLE]
JOYCE BAZ: Last question.
AUDIENCE: This is
going to be a fun one.
JOYCE BAZ: Oh?
AUDIENCE: I know you've had
a lot of serious questions.
JOYCE BAZ: Good to know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Sorry?
JOYCE BAZ: Good
positive note to end on.
AUDIENCE: Good positive note.
So you mentioned the
media [INAUDIBLE]..
how we accessed
[INAUDIBLE] before we
had to wait till we buy
the newspaper and all that.
So if you get to define one kind
of technological advancement
'or like something in the
Internet of Things that
would basically either help
people to reach out to media
or to read the media,
to be more informed
and to get actual news,
instead of fake news,
what would be like your dream
new device or invention?
MINA AL ORIABI: OK,
so I have two answers
because my first answer
is, did you guys ever see
the movie "Minority Report?"
Right, so that
image of Tom Cruise?
Yeah, it was Tom Cruise.
Tom Cruise was in the Emirates.
Tom Cruise holding the
newspaper that gets
updated automatically,
which I guess it's
like the modern-day tablet.
But I wish it could be a
newspaper that gets updated.
So that's like kind
of my crazy dream.
If I could have
anything, my newspaper
would stay updating, while
still being a newspaper.
But if I can't have
that, my second thing
is I guess is exactly the point
that you said about fake news.
So if there is a way that we
can distinguish trusted news
sources and not trusted
or even if they're
trusted-- kind of like,
who's the ownership?
Like, let people know,
what's the ownership?
Where's it coming from?
What is that?
But there's a way
that we can signal
that so people know what to
take and what not to take,
that would be the dream.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, great.
JOYCE BAZ: Mina, on
behalf of all Googlers,
I thank you very much for
sharing such candid thoughts
and insights with us.
Thank you again.
And please do stay around
and have some great food.
It's all healthy-- we promise.
And thank you again.
Thanks to [INAUDIBLE],,
Dena, and Miriam.
MINA AL ORIABI: Thank you.
JOYCE BAZ: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]